Mallika Sarabhai
MALLIKA: First of all you have to look at
the economy and our own happiness and the
environment as competing for it as a no-no,
and while the going was good, a lot of business
was looking at it that way, that they could
make a profit and it didn't matter that the
environment was being destroyed. And it's
only after this downturn that people are even
asking these questions, it is [ INAUDIBLE
] asking these questions. I agree with this
that it has to be something that goes side-by-side
and not something that is if this wins, this
looses, because it can't be. However much
money [ INAUDIBLE ] the Midas touch bit, that
you touch a piece of earth and it disappears.
And yes, more action is required from all
of us. Every drop of water we save every tree
we don't break down is going to make a difference,
so let's make it now, today and every moment.